قد يكون زئير ملك الغابه مؤشرا على انه في
حاجه الى مزيد من الطعام في حديقه صنعاء
للحيوانات في حاجه ماسه الى توفير الغذاء
الكافي للحيوانات المختلفه التي يتزايد
عددها نتيجه للتكاثر
الحيوان في 2019 19
حديقه صنعاء تحتوي على عدد كبير من الطيور
والزواحف والحيوانات المفترسه النادره
ولكنها تحتاج الى تحديث مبانيها والى
زياده مواردها المحدوده
لكثره الموارد والكثره الحيوانات
كذلك نتضل الى زياده كميه التغذيه
همم بما يتناسب مع المواليد الجديده روح
خطوره على المنبه لا يستطيع الدخول الى
الاحواش للنظافه
وكذلك توزيع التغذيه تغيير مياه الشرب هذه
يكون خطوره على المنبه
تجذب حديقه صنعاء للحيوانات العديده من
اليمنيين من صنعاء ومن المحافظات المجاوره